my name is zia shaikh i am 35 years old
i am chef to cuisine at pawalo
restaurant and i make 75 000 a year my
main responsibilities at sheffield
cuisine is to oversee any type of
kitchen operation from menu development
to dishwashing to working alongside the
cooks to food labor costs sitting down
with chef floyd for about 10 to 15
minutes a day we talk about what's
coming down uh the line as far as menu
we are very highly seasonal restaurants
we try to use the uni square green
market as much as possible as well as
local farms if it's not in season it's
not on our menu i almost want to say
that this career chose me
i dealt with a lot of racism in school
when i was growing up so i spent a lot
of time at home
that being said i spent a lot of time to
myself and i realized that i had a love
for the arts i i spent a lot of time
with my mother at home in the kitchen so
she actually taught me how to start
cooking when i was 10 years old and the
first thing that i made at home was
her meatballs she was cooking meatballs
for the family and i started mimicking
her moves in a smaller pot for myself
right next to her
and ever since then i've just i've
fallen in love with cooking it was so
interesting to me
whereas a year or two later i started
accompanying her to supermarkets and
buying my own produce i taught myself
how to hold a knife how to cut
vegetables my favorite thing to make was
vegetable stir-fry just because it
involved about 20 different vegetables
in one dish
my father passed away when i was 16
he was always pushing me to do something
with science and almost to make him
happy after he passed away i enrolled in
engineering school but then when i got
to engineering school i realized i just
didn't have a passion for it that same
semester one of my close friends mary
wanted to do something nice for her
boyfriend for valentine's day
so she invited me and about five other
friends into the kitchen with her to
cook for her boyfriend
and
between me and these
these five other
girls
they were all impressed that i knew my
way around the kitchen and i almost kind
of took over after that i was just kind
of staring at me in the face what i
should be doing with my life so i
dropped out of college and went to
culinary school now that you're in a
restaurant setting you realize that
everything happens at a much faster pace
and
you're working alongside more
experienced cooks that can cut faster
that can cook faster that can think
faster and
basically the point of the externship is
for you to be immersed in a new type of
world my very first job i was making 300
a week working in the kitchen i was
doing what i love to do but i didn't
have a lot of money to to spare so
they my mother let me still live at home
uh it's not ideal for a 23 24 year old
to be living at home but at the time it
was what was necessary to do whatever
money i had left over whatever money i
saved up to buy cookbooks to keep
reading to immerse myself in this world
to take myself to the next level and
i dined out a lot of restaurants i
cooked for myself a lot at home just
testing out new recipes and whatnot i
did a lot of this at work i almost
bugged my chefs with questions about you
know can you teach me this can you teach
me this can you teach me this and i
started taking on more and more tasks to
see what i could handle and what i
enjoyed doing
and
starting out you will take any job you
can uh for any amount of money uh for to
learn any part of it um
i used to switch jobs for 50 cents more
if they paid me and
you know at the time i moved around a
lot i didn't keep a job more than for
more than 10 months and then i went on
to another job after that but it was all
learning experience